thanks to brilliant the website and app
designed to supplement classroom
learning for sponsoring this video
in world war ii american soldiers fended
off attacks by insects using a novel
weapon the bug bomb this was a
pressurized steel can that contained an
insect repellent when opened the
repellent would spray over a wide area
pushed out of the can by a propellant
this design caught on and soon aerosol
spray cans were being used for paint
deodorant hairspray you name it and the
propellant in these cans was typically
something called freon which was an
example of a refrigerant you actually
find it in refrigerators as well
chemically it's what's known as a
chlorofluorocarbon or cfc which was this
marvel of modern chemistry that had a
wide variety of uses however it was
eventually realized that these wonder
molecules were actually unintentionally
destroying a section of the earth's
atmosphere the ozone layer ozone or o3
naturally forms in the earth's middle
atmosphere due to sunlight splitting
apart oxygen molecules forming a
particularly dense layer around 25
kilometers above the surface that we
call the ozone layer but it's a pretty
fuzzy ill-defined layer it's significant
because ozone is extremely effective at
absorbing ultraviolet radiation you know
the kind that causes skin cancer and for
life to generally have a not fun time
ozone provides a protective force field
around the planet reducing the intensity
of uv radiation at the surface by a
factor of approximately 350 million
or i should say it did because it was
discovered in the 1970s that cfcs in
aerosol cans and refrigerators destroyed
atmospheric ozone to the extent that an
area of particularly low ozone
concentration was detected over the
south pole in the southern hemisphere
spring that became known as the hull in
the ozone layer this hole and the entire
layer really varies a lot year by year
depending on how air is moving around in
the stratosphere and potentially also
what the sun is doing the hull closed
and reopened every year but over the
years it became apparent that its
maximum extent was getting bigger and
bigger if this was allowed to continue
then there was a chance that the earth
would lose its force field against uv
radiation if that happened it would mean
a lot more people getting things like
skin cancer and a whole range of other
effects that we'd really rather avoid so
the international community listened to
the scientists heeded their warning and
rapidly implemented an international
agreement that curbed the problem before
it got too bad
wait what this this literally never
happens in 1987 the montreal protocol
was signed gradually phasing out the use
of cfcs and this protocol really worked
emissions of cfcs plummeted
concentrations of cfcs in the atmosphere
peaked and then fell and the
concentration of ozone in the atmosphere
has been gradually recovering and the
whole closing with year-to-year
variability it's expected that by the
mid 21st century the ozone layer will
have basically healed former secretary
general of the united nations kofi annan
described the protocol as perhaps the
single most successful international
agreement to date with it we avoided the
nightmare scenario of the earth's
surface being flooded by ultraviolet
radiation but
perhaps that's not all we avoided before
i get to that point though let me just
ask the question
why can't we do this with climate change
if we have an international agreement
that clearly worked at curbing emissions
of cfcs why can't we just get a new
agreement that does the same thing for
greenhouse gases like co2 well for one
thing we actually have the protocol has
been amended several times since it was
signed most recently in 2016 with the
kigali amendment that extended the ban
on cfcs under the protocol to a related
family of chemicals called
hydrofluorocarbons or hfcs that are also
used as refrigerants they don't destroy
ozone but they are extremely potent
greenhouse gases so the international
community figured that we had this
protocol that really effectively banned
a similar kind of chemical for the same
purpose so let's just extend the
remember the protocol of it in fact you
could argue that with the kigali
amendment the montreal protocol has kind
of become the most effective piece of
legislation to curb greenhouse gas
emissions to date but that's not what
this video is about the problem with
limiting greenhouse gas emissions in
general is that they're inherent to the
way we live our lives every time we make
electricity or drive a car or grow food
we produce greenhouse gases cfcs were
used in quite limited applications with
alternate propellants and refrigerants
available so they could be legislated
and eventually banned really quite
easily the longer we keep emitting large
quantities of greenhouse gases however
the worse our future looks and the
sooner we run into the really bad
potential effects like widespread
extreme weather events drought famine
and mass extinctions of species but it
turns out that the montreal protocol
might have bought us some time in this
because for a while now scientists have
been asking the question what if we
never signed the montreal protocol what
if we kept emitting cfcs and imagine the
world that we avoided by taking action
it's estimated that without the protocol
the earth's ozone layer would have
completely collapsed by the mid 21st
century resulting in the surface being
flooded with uv radiation this avoided
future has been examined from a health
perspective it's found that we will have
avoided tens of millions of deaths from
skin cancer by the end of the 21st
century by passing the protocol but with
more relevance to our story it's also
been examined from a climate change
perspective because as well as
destroying ozone cfcs are also very
potent greenhouse gases trapping heat in
the earth's lower atmosphere far more
effectively than co2 or methane and so
by limiting the emission of cfcs we've
prevented some warming taking place
potentially three or four degrees of
warming by the end of the century but
that's just the direct insulating effect
of those gases in a new paper this year
an additional impact has been examined
and it's a big one how would the world's
biosphere meaning all life on earth
forests algae animals everything have
responded to all that extra uv young at
al 2021 published in nature compares a
realistic but maybe a little pessimistic
projection of the earth's climate rcp6
with that same projection but with
continuing rising cfc emissions as if we
never passed the montreal protocol these
were referred to as the world projected
and the world avoided scenarios
respectively they found that as in
previous studies the ozone layer
collapsed midway through the century in
the world avoided scenario but crucially
they then examined how much extra uv was
reaching the surface and based on a
meta-analysis of several previous
studies modeled how the biosphere would
react in the world avoided i'm
simplifying here but they effectively
assumed that for each 10 increase in uv
reaching the surface plant life became
three percent less efficient at sucking
carbon out of the atmosphere this is
because when plants are radiated by uv
radiation photosynthesis becomes less
efficient the result of this was
shocking the world's biosphere saw a
precipitous drop in how much carbon it
was removing from the atmosphere by the
year 2100 in the world avoided scenario
there was between
325 and 690 giga tons of carbon in the
atmosphere that would otherwise have
been in the biosphere that corresponds
to the concentration of co2 in the
atmosphere being between
115 and 235
parts per million higher in other words
by passing the montreal protocol we
avoided a potential nightmare scenario
in which the earth's surface was flooded
by uv radiation and via feedback in the
biosphere atmospheric co2 concentrations
by the end of the century would be as
high as 900 parts per million
more than double what they are
now
and that would be accompanied by a lot
of warming perhaps six degrees celsius
by the end of the century though there'd
be further warming after that compare
that to the three degrees celsius under
the world projected scenario by passing
the montreal protocol this paper claims
we unintentionally avoided a catastrophe
in the biosphere where it was flooded by
uv and became far less effective as a
carbon sink of course this paper has
limitations it makes assumptions about
how cfc emissions would continue to rise
and how plants would respond to
extremely high concentrations of uv
light but these assumptions are in line
with other papers in the field and
they're based on the best data that we
have available regardless this is still
a useful piece of work as to quote the
authors an order of magnitude estimate
of the effect of the montreal protocol
on the ozone uv biosphere carbon cycle
climate system it's almost as if
everything is interconnected something
that i'd like to stress though is that
just because we passed the montreal
protocol doesn't mean that we fixed
climate change if we hadn't passed it
then we might have been running into
some really bad stuff in the next decade
or two whereas as it stands we're still
gonna run into that stuff but in the
second half of this century the protocol
basically bought us some time but not
much of it and now we have to use that
time to bring down our greenhouse gas
emissions the montreal protocol shows us
that it can be done we have precedent
for an international environmental
agreement that works in fact though
legislators at the time could never have
known it really worked and helped the
planet and the climate avoid a real
catastrophe
sunlight is filtered through the earth's
atmosphere before it reaches the surface
as we've seen that's partly accomplished
by ozone absorbing uv radiation but
there are other gases at play notably
water vapor and carbon dioxide as we see
in this figure if sunlight is mostly
between 400 and 2400 nanometers in
wavelength what proportion of sunlight
incident on the earth do you think
reaches the surface
this is an example problem from
brilliant who have kindly sponsored this
video brilliant is an educational
website and app designed to complement
classroom learning and provide a fun
interactive learning experience for
students and professionals alike just as
we saw in this trial problem the
emphasis is put on problem solving not
rote learning and many of their expertly
written modules feature interactive
puzzles this one was on solar energy but
there are others across maths science
and computer science including learning
python computational biology and linear
algebra to name just a few brilliant is
available on its website but also as a
mobile app making it perfect for
spending a few minutes a day on your
commute or on your sofa improving your
understanding and sharpening your
problem solving skills i've said it
several times but i'll say it again i
wish brilliant had been around when i
was a student because it's a perfect
complementary resource to classroom or
lecture hall learning you improve your
understanding so much by looking at the
same topic from multiple angles from
multiple sources and that's exactly what
brilliant allows you to do you can get
yourself access to all this and more by
going to brilliant.org simon clark
linked in the description and the first
200 people to do so will get 20 off
their annual premium subscription doing
so you support this channel and your own
learning that's brilliant.org simon
clark
thank you so much for watching the video
i really hope that you enjoyed this one
it's the second in a series that i hope
will be ongoing where i take new papers
in atmospheric science and basically try
to translate them for a youtube audience
if you did enjoy this video then you can
watch the first one in this series over
here and you can also pop the video a
like and if you think that other people
might enjoy it then maybe you should
share it with them if you're new here
please do also subscribe and get
notified about all my new videos and
that just leaves me to say thank you
again for watching and i'll see you in
the next one